but that's why marketing is so powerful
right it's like it's for the same reason
it's making you think you want something
that you don't actually want it's mind
games and I fall for it every and then
look at how bad the Auto industry tried
to make the infrastructure car friendly
like that's another game how so I don't
[Laughter]
[Music]
know a Filipino American nurse wins $41
million oh my goodness in a retaliation
lawsuit against Kaiser m anes m a
retaliation of Temporaries thank you so
was she like I'm telling you that
Jollibee is the best and then the Kaiser
Permanente was like KFC is way better
and then she goes no and then they fired
her yeah yeah because of her
discrimination against Jollibee this is
a retaliation l so so they did something
to wrong her and she's like I don't
think that's right yeah she fired they
fired her cuz she likes Jolly Be
termination retaliation lawsuit it is
not when someone Lo uh sues you and you
sue them back right nope that's a
countersuit okay that's retaliating oh
yeah you want to do that way better yep
D 41 million is quite a bit I wonder
what it was yeah what was it so she said
so Kaiser says that she placed her bare
feet on a medical device for sick or
premature newborns oh the defense said
her conduct was uh
unacceptable especially as she was a
charge nurse Kaiser claimed to have lost
confidence in her and made the decision
to terminate her okay so Kaiser is the
defense right because she is she's
saying hey this is messed up I want
restitution so she was just being a
regular Asian Aunt using her bare feet
like it's her other like it's her hands
picking stuff up you know a lot of my
jungle Asian friends they use all four
you know what I'm saying they don't just
use hands they use feet and hands well
she like oh that's just my culture I
like to do things in bare feet cuz
Asians take their shoes off she did not
she said was a a safety issue so check
this out so during the trial Witnesses
supported claims of understaffing at the
facility right um her lawyer argued that
staffing issues in healthcare are linked
to Care Quality and the lawsuit said
that Kaiser discouraged formal
complaints using the standard procedure
about patient safety and quality aiming
to avoid investigation that's what they
do though so so she had the courage to
be a whistleblower and speak up about
patient safety and Kaiser tried to
silence her and then the jury spoke in a
loud and clear voice telling Kaiser it
needs to put patience above profits
awarding her compensation of 11.49
million in comp compensatory damages 9
million for emotional distress and 30
million in punitive damages when youever
you talk someone that works in
healthcare especially in the past like 2
three years the biggest problem they say
underst Staffing yeah across the board
and they're like we're getting way too
much work there's no way we could deal
with this many patients and actually
give the adequate that care that they
need so therefore like we're all at a
loss here but then like the the hups
they may not want to like uh they they
don't want to go through the process of
hiring more people and going through all
that [__] they want to pay that many
people they retaliate because she is
trying to raise issues about what's
going on at Kaiser right and then they
basically said okay you did a minor
policy infraction putting her bare feet
on a medical device right and we're
going to terminate you we going get you
y and so that's what she said and she
likes Jolly be better than KFC and
that's another part of the lawsuit that
was part two that's actually the reason
why she won yeah but I've I have friends
that have friends of friends in
healthcare where they were over they're
underst staffed and they're working
overtime and the they try to tell you
like don't go don't do overtime don't do
overtime and then this girl would clock
out to work after and then that becomes
an issue and this something that she
continues to do and they fired her for
that what for working being off of the
clock oh cuz she's cuz she's a liability
yeah so it's like all this so it's like
which one am I supposed to do like am I
supposed to get the work done am I
supposed to write all the stuff out for
like the charts for my my patients or am
I supposed to do overtime so it's like
this it's it's this weird thing and then
if they [__] with you if you don't like
you or if you kind of talk back to the
higher ups they might be like you know
[__] you we're going to fire at how
about like they just teach us how to be
healthy so we don't got to go to the
hospital nobody want to hear all that
bro no they won't
dude I mean I'm just saying this now as
a able-body young man um but I'm just
saying okay aside from eating nutritious
foods and then Fitness to keep the you
know sicknesses away like why are there
so many [__] people at the hospital
and I say this because like when you
look at the top five causes of death
it's
all like it's all it's all it's all it's
all preventable and and it's habit it's
them they did it it's all free [__] like
sleeping more walking around more
getting more sunlight drinking more
water it's so it's like imagine if the
hospitals didn't have all of that so
it's like diabetes like people getting
whatever like all these complications
it's a lifestyle decision that got them
there and I'm like how do we [__]
solve that so then the hospital doesn't
have that many people we vote for RFK
RFK that's what he's been talking about
chme I was just listening to an audio
book tell me about that [__] it's called
outlive I'm not trying to promote it I'm
not being paid to promote it but I just
started listening to it as an Audi book
and it was talking about this exact same
situation where the healthare system is
like they would rather do certain things
that's [__] up to the patient so they
could avoid lawsuits like this because
they lose way more money if you know
whatever whatever but then in this case
uh CH won which is really good for that
but there was this doctor that basically
was tired of how like his Superior kept
saying don't do this even though this is
better for the patient they're like oh
but we want to go by the rules and blah
blah blah blah yeah cuz they're afraid
of being sued too and I would say in the
hospital's defense a lot of them get
taken down because of lawsuits right so
like they have to kind of think of
lawsuits first cuz they're like well how
the [__] am I going to continue this
hospital then which sucks cuz it should
be no should think about how to best
take care of the patient first right but
then that nobody likes that should be
but what sexy choice so so here's here's
my Counterpoint is like that should be
right what if that was the policy and
then they get sued up the ass they lose
all this money now they go we got to be
compliant all the time and put
compliance first and then yes you know
like it's it to me it's not just one way
one bad guy it's like they're reacting
to each other microcosm time I know
somebody who works in V veterinary care
and they recently had their um vet
office bought by a a corporation so it
was like a mom and pop vet shop that
slowly grew and then they got bought by
a corporation the two people who led the
thing go vacation in Bermuda forever and
then everyone's left with the
consequences of now the corporate
environment coming in and trying to
maximize profits in every single dime
getting squeezed so now they fire a
bunch of Vette techs right they make
they they put a lot of the pressure on
the vet veterinarians and then they try
to even squeeze that down even more so
like this person can't they have
patience right so it's like a a cat or
dog or [__] [__] to and and you know
what's going on with your patient right
but they don't let you work on your
patient consistently they consistently
have you Shuffle the paperwork to
somebody else so they don't have to pay
you overtime wow damn it's all [__]
racket man it dude and it's just about
squeeze in every ring you can and it's
not about the customer anymore it's
about maximizing profits and that's the
corporate environment but you know what
I believe like is the solution like you
were talking about earlier is like how
do you change your own lifestyle so that
you avoid having to end up in places
like this in the first place and it's
always exercise diet whatever lifestyle
Wellness you know exactly but then you
can't sell that really cuz it's I can
that I sawell that on my website
ning.com he literally sells it yeah like
I think like the number one cause of
death for men is um heart diseases like
yeah stress cardiovascular diseases
diabetes overweight cancer but a lot of
those things are triggered by like poor
life choices and it's stuff that can be
easily reversed because it's it's spans
over a long time period you can start
changing it now if you do a little every
day yeah exactly
even if the even if the government did a
massive campaign to promote this
ideal what makes people change their
habits you know that's the tough part
you want what about marketing but what
if they straight up told you like hey
yeah we [__] up pyramid's [__] all
this stuff's [__] people for a day
might be like I told you and then just
keep eating whatever's like how do we
make people like hard people are already
starting to change that and starting to
go against the the P the food pyramid or
whatever there's already a bunch of like
like people that believe that oh this is
you know the right way for health it's
small look here check this out right so
so this recently was uncovered the sugar
industry basically gaslit everybody paid
for a marketing campaign that basically
said that hey guess what all they did
all these studies too like hey all all
this meat is really bad for you it's
like going to give you heart disease and
kill you but what what they determined
later is actually it was all the sugar
and [__] I'm giving you that but that's
what they do they're so good at it's
like the cereal thing so you're saying
ceros aren't good for your heart well no
they they had a whole thing where they
stopped making cereal be marketed in
that way right and what's crazy it's
like like just to play Devil's Advocate
like if there's big food right we also
all know and on every single nutrition
fact that tells you like the daily
average is like what like 2,200 calories
or something like that so we all know if
you eat more than 2200 calories you're
going to gain weight so it's like there
is a technically surgeon general's on
everything but we don't follow it well
they have nothing to compare to they
like most people when you talk to them
like for nutrition stuff like they don't
they get calories but it's just like
some abstract [__] thing like yeah
right right right and like so for them
to actually put it into effect in their
day-to-day like it's it is kind of a
barrier for a lot of people cuz they
don't teach a [__] in school bro they
should be teaching you about like
macronutrients in school well I mean
they did teach us about the food pyramid
and a lot of us followed it and got
[__] up so it's like there were things
things in the past where I think they
tried and then it got infiltrated by
companies that wanted to sell and then
it got [__] up you know I think they
need to make it more straight up like
starting it's hard to like let's let's
say we were like ah [__] [__] the
current adults in schools now just be
straight up you eat this you're going to
be fat and die early if you eat this
you're going to be healthy and then make
PE really hard across the board dude you
know where it's at make it really hard I
think Nick's got to become a Tik Tok
influencer and like tell the people the
truth and then go viral and then the
younger gener there's a ton of those
though that's what I'm saying but Nick's
got to do it but but the thing about
that [__] though especially in the
health space is like everyone has that
in their own category like carnivore
guys have it keto guys have like so and
then and then the normal consumer is
like well who the [__] do I listen to so
given given now that we have so much
proof and so much data that the food
industry does all these different tricks
to try to get us to consume more harmful
stuff do I sound like a conspiracy
theorist when I say that there's got to
be some connection between the food
they're marketing out and the
championing of obese
people no no more fat shaming but I
think it's like a feelings thing no yeah
but is that in a way like you know
people would go well what do they have
to gain by making us love being fat yeah
like here that's one eat more sugar like
well I don't want to be fat but like but
like your favorite singer's fat though
and also too so it's okay sure I'll eat
more sugar as people have more health
problems they have to
they have to lean on our healthare
system and our healthare system like it
seems
like the hospitals are like against the
insurance companies and vice versa
they're like they're battling each other
and then the hospitals are also like
battling against like their patients in
a way right right so it's like they're
trying to constantly push like oh well
you need this like you need dude that's
why you need fat shamers right Nick is
that what you're saying well look kind
of kind of like if we're keep it a bug I
honestly think so I think so dude say
hey you're a fat [__] or whatever
stra it's like it doesn't really fat
roers I could kind of think of one one
example of some something that lost so
big tobacco kind of lost like it used to
be pretty common um but through the
sheer like powers of people like they
didn't have to fight and say you can't
do tobacco ads they didn't have to say
you can't have that in films and
whatever you know and then they banned
it in schools they banned it in like you
know dining plac and whatever and it
kind of became the social stigma if
you're still a smoker and we saw that
happen within our lifetime when like
maybe our brothers or parents'
generation you were able to smoke
cigarettes at school and then so like if
they if this was possible then maybe in
the food industry it can be possible too
I just don't know how but look at
tobacco though right they did a pivot
what's the pivot vaping people are
vaping way more they're it's way more
accessible and we still don't really
know how like dangerous it is right
right and to me that's harmful not
knowing yeah cuz we'll see what happens
but like the way you see some like I
don't know if you have buddies that
smoke Vapes like these [__] are
sucking it down every yeah and they
they're like oh my God where's my you
know they're always like even for me
like like I I was using like a marijuana
Vape for a little bit and then you kind
of get in a habit of like it's your
pacifier yeah and then you just you just
[__] hitting it all day and all of a
sudden you're like what the [__] am I
doing to my body bro like why do I have
to have this need of like oh where's my
vape where's my vape yeah there's such a
chicken chicken of the egg Factor where
it's like when you know people are like
oh but the the public wants more of this
sugar they want more of this meat but I
think evidence has shown us that like
when there's a projected prediction
let's say that they made too much
[__] bacon or whatever yeah and then
your state whatever your state makes
whether it's potatoes [__] poultry
whatever they have too much of a surplus
they're going to market the [__] out of
that that year yeah so then it's like if
the more people don't want something
then the Lesser they keep doing their
projected prediction then maybe we can
finally over time get to a point where
there's less of that thing they don't
have to power Market it yeah you know
like it's like milk it's like we had to
[__] drink so much goddamn milk cuz
they had too many [__] cows y now
nobody drinks milk everybody wants oat
milk [__] but then it goes like this
it's like oh demand Supply demand Supply
demand Supply but it'll never go demand
if it doesn't make any money they're not
going to keep producing it right but
it'll be slow because they have to keep
like kind of gauging it and then going
lesser and lesser we're all sucking on
the tee dude yeah the cow's te the cow
tee the nicotine tee the [__] dude
it's always a tee caffeine you know what
I mean we're all on it love caffeine but
it's the same way you you could look at
car markets in the exact same way you're
being marketed these specific cars cuz
that's what we [__] make I don't want
to [__] Isuzu anymore but that's why
marketing but that's why marketing is so
powerful right it's like it's for the
same reason it's making you think you
want something that you don't actually
want it's mind games and I [__] fall
for it every single time and then look
at how bad the Auto industry tried to
make the [__] infrastructure car
friendly like that's another game how so
I don't
know for like another can of worms let's
just let's just keep it going make it
notr top [__] public transportation
yeah all right well this is a this is a
conspiracy theory during the time that
it was happening that became true and
it's in our Good Old City Los Angeles
you can look this up but Back in the Day
LA had a ton of Trolley Street cars you
know like the one that you see in Mr
Rogers and all that and the ones in San
Francisco They said that this was the
place where you can go from anywhere you
have your own Victorian home and there's
going to be a street car cuz that's what
they call those troles a street car in
every city that c and they they had a
grid it came all the way from downtown
to Santa Monica Pier you could ride that
for like 5 cents it was it was like this
accessible public thing right you still
see the rails on the ground today so
what the automobile industry did was
they bought they created all these shell
corpse like fake corporations and they
said oh we're going to buy these we're
going to privatize it and then we're
going to um get into the industry but
what they ended up doing was they bought
it they defun it m wow and so now
there's no street cars right and then
they just started pumping Autos like you
know and selling those all over La cuz
they saw the future of LA and California
they're like this is a wide state that
needs road yeah driving culture exactly
and then they colluded with the
government and then you know how
um all of the military like like Highway
you know the the highways that we have
the interstates that was for military
logistics but also the car industry
pushed the government to do it so then
they can make this like whole Nationwide
driving thing I did not know about this
that's awesome but it's it's pretty wild
right cuz it's like that's how you
become hella rich is like but it makes
sense though right like you could be
like oh I could totally see a bunch of
people colluding to do that right that
makes that's the most real food isn't
just oh eat this bacon it's not just
that it's like you have to because
there's 50 things around you that are
telling you that's all we've got that's
the cheapest thing supply and demand we
made too much of it love bacon and we
and we predicted you would eat this much
bacon for the next 30 Years so you have
to eat it it's bigger than just like do
I want and it's like oh your bacon is
selling really well let's let's keep
pumping it don't you eat it and go I
hate how right you are and how delicious
this [__] is but that's where
government and corporations should not
get toook mangle cuz you had you had
this Corporation come in buy these this
Trolley system and then screw over
everybody in California but the deals
are too good that's why I think that
we're now being lobbied in I mean we
always have but it's more clearer now
that we're being lobbied into the social
sentiment of like oh the last ditch
effort is like we're all fat and dying
help us no you're not fat and dying
you're fine Beau the way you are it's
really [__] scary because that was
supposed to be the only thing you
couldn't and then you know what's crazy
it's like tag team wrestling cuz they
have that right no you're beautiful
you're fat the way you are whatever and
then now it's like oh you know what big
Pharma jump in oh we got OIC you want to
lose weight take this thing so it's just
like one homie tagging in another homie
tagging another homie and then now you
go down the whole chain and you're
spending money all the way across the
board I think the [__] up thing here
is that like people think the solution
is like government or or the other side
is private sector right and for me the
solution is stopping the corruption cuz
like you you can't look at it as like
just business and billionaires are the
corrupt ones you can't look at it as
like government is the stupid corrupt
one like they're working together for
this whole system to happen they both
need to work together to make it happen
and I'm like how come people can't see
that how come they think about it as
like oh the Democrats were the good guys
or like the Republicans were the good
guys and it's like are you stupid no
everyone's working together to make the
collusion happen and I'm like the good
guys are being sued out of existence and
Destroy like the like the documentary
about who killed the electric car like
we could have had electric cars way the
[__] long time ago we could have had
hydrogen powered cars we could have had
all kinds of different alternative
vehicles and they just get killed off
one after another people can't make like
money off of it yeah because you're not
going to challenge these dudes yeah
you're threatening a whole ecosystem
that's why I don't I don't entirely
blame anyone who's fat that that's their
fault like there's a whole
infrastructure around them that's
validating exactly what they're doing
and just saying sh just keep doing it
just keep doing it fat means you're
happy it's not completely on you it's
like there's a yeah you can make the
choice but it makes it very hard to make
that choice but go to ND tr.com
n.com Nick you're you're saving the
generations to come I try man we try
back in the day much we can if you're
fat everyone's like dude that's that
guy's [__] Rich that's true hey in
the Philippines it's still
true bring back graceful bullying the
end just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kidding news the number one
foodcast in the
[Music]
world